the jury's decision in favor of johnny
depp in his defamation suit against
amber heard came down to the details of
that particular case but some argue that
this verdict could have broader
implications for the metoo movement and
discourage women from coming forward
with their own stories of abuse we're
joined now by new york times
investigative reporter jody cantor you
know her well because she helped spark
the metoo movement back in 2017 with her
allegations her reporting rather on the
allegations against harvey weinstein
jody good to have you back at the table
you're the perfect person to to talk to
this case about because there are a lot
of chatter about now this is going to
set the metoo movement back
um that amber heard was
for whatever reason not believed
what is your take on the case does it
set the metoo movement back
well you know in many ways this did not
resemble a classic me too case this kind
of belongs to the tradition also of
celebrity trials that turn into public
spectacle
this was a very bitter divorce in which
these two celebrities personal lives
kind of tumbled out into public view
there were some metoo allegations here
there were some allegations of sexual
violence and i think the relationship to
me too is the worry that there could be
a chilling effect on women coming
forward do you feel that well the way
amber heard was attacked was in one
sense very familiar there was a lot of
misogyny that we've seen before by the
public by the public and especially
online there was kind of a weaponization
of the reputational warfare online there
was almost this hate machine built
against her have you ever seen anything
like that i had never seen it at that
level
and directed at one woman at
that intensity
what did you make of a split verdict i
mean he went overwhelmingly he won all
of his all the accounts yeah
but like everything else about this case
it's just messy there are not clear
black and white conclusions here
i mean
is is that really the case i mean that
there does seem to be a
a definite as you point out online
preponderance of support for johnny depp
so much so that people are coming up
with all these theories as to why it may
could could be the facts and you have
the jury on the three counts siding with
him she won on only one count uh and it
involves something that johnny's lawyer
said right um so is it really a 50-50 no
one wins here or did johnny depp take
this one well i don't think it's 50 50
but it but it was a very unusual kind of
split cross verdict yeah which each side
uh was blamed a bit but in the court of
public opinion i mean that's where
the
the i mean this trial was conducted like
a sports event that was shown live on tv
with it may have been slightly familiar
to you with with you know it must have
been surreal watching a trial play out
in that way and the cheering for johnny
depp but also the desire to belittle
herd is really i think that the legacy
and what's so overwhelming it seemed
like johnny depp was the home team yeah
we're cheering for the home team and
yeah
you say that the fact that amber heard
faced a defamation lawsuit
is scary to all women why so so that's
really important because even though
this is a very very high profile case
it's not singular we have seen seen
other instances in which
defamation lawsuits have been brought
against women who came forward with me
too allegations so that's a very scary
prospect for women who are contemplating
that's what that's what i'm wondering do
you think that this will hurt other
women who may be thinking about coming
forward should that be the lesson watch
out or should is it an isolated case
with its own particular details and
other women should still feel confident
coming forward every case is different
but i think first of all you're right
this was pretty singular most women
don't have amber hurts liberty they're
not going up against johnny depp with
his fans so i i think you're right to
caution about extrapolating too much
from this but
when i've spent a lot of time with women
who are deliberating coming forward
about something and they are looking in
the public square you know years ago it
was well what about what happened to
trump what about what happened to cosby
you know like how do i consider my own
story and decisions in light of what
they're going through and so i do think
women will look at amber heard and say
i'm not equipped to go through something
like that whether it will be
determinative
for them i don't know but because this
trial just got so much attention i think
it will be a factor for them cody we
appreciate you thank you so much thank
you